hi this is ife i'm yosonan we're from
mulan and we're here to see which disney
princess suits us best
[Music]
first question uh choose a sidekick to
help you get through troubling times the
first one is mushu
the second one is mikko third one is
pascal and then sebastian
lumea and raja yeah i picked mushu so
cute
i'm gonna pick lumiere because he can
serenade me
which is your ideal living location a
beach house at lake house deep in the
forest
a cozy mountain town bearing land lush
hotel i mean they're all pretty good i
personally i think i'm gonna go with the
lake house
because i like the forest and water so i
get the best of both worlds
maybe i do the a beach house because i
like scuba diving
what quality do you look for in a
partner honesty adventurous
kind loyal sense of humor and smart i
kind of want more than just one of these
you know
i think most important one you gotta be
kind right you're gonna be kind i'm
gonna choose the same thing
which dessert best fits your personality
birthday cake
apple pie chocolate brownie with ice
cream
double chocolate cake tiramisu fruit
tart
they all look so good and dangerous
right i'll choose apple pie apple pie i
gotta go with tiramisu because
i grew up eating that like a lot of it
finally choose a non-princess
disney movie the aristocats the lion
king
jungle book alice in wonderland lilo and
stitch
and peter pan oh that's this is tough
they're all so
good go first you want to go liking i
want to go lilo and stitch
oh wow jasmine belle jasmine
or belle yeah i got rapunzel and ariel
on the inside you're rapunzel you're
quirky funny and a little weird i am
very weird you also have a soft romantic
side
on the outside you're ariel you march to
the beat of your own drum
you can be a little bit impulsive but
it's only because you're so adventurous
your smile is infectious oh thanks
you got jasmine belle on the inside your
adjustment you have a bit of
spitfire personality but you keep it
under control yeah
you've learned to think before you speak
in order not to hurt your loved ones
you might not look the type but you
crave
adventure and romance you want to
be swept away on the outside your belt
you often take people by surprise when
it comes to stand
standing up for what you believe in you
are
bookworm and and introvert
but you also love going out and see the
good in everyone oh my god that is so
you yeah that is so cute
wow that's pretty accurate
you